mein name ist nina schenk und ich freue
mich heute abend ihre gastgeberin sein
zu dürfen ein aufreger des tages ist
heute kein aufreger sondern eine bitte
ein autor des englischen telegraph hat
die korona maßnahmen kritiker um
entschuldigung gebeten ich finde das
großartig und bitte darum dass wir uns
in deutschland in dem telegraph autor
ein beispiel nehmen wir brauchen eine
massive krone entschuldigungs welle im
deutschen journalismus
der grund wie andere meinungen
hierzulande bei vielen medien bei vielen
journalisten in den letzten jahren
ausgegrenzt wurde war einfach nicht
richtig man darf fehler machen aber ich
finde dann sollte man sich entschuldigen
eine kurze kostprobe weil mit zwei
statements der ard swr journalist
reinhard becker sagte zitat all diesen
spinnern und corona kritikern sei gesagt
es wird keine normalität mehr geben wie
vorher als der politik chef nikolaus
blome liegen sogar noch weiter als er
sagte ich hingegen möchte an dieser
stelle ausdrücklich um gesellschaftliche
nachteile für all jene ersuchen die
freiwillig auf eine impfung verzichten
möge die gesamte republik mit dem finger
auf sie zeigen
wann haben politische maßnahmen jemals
diesen beifall erhalten und können
regelungen und pharmazeutische produkte
war ob die jemals so gut sein dass es
seitens journalismus so wenig den
letzten zweieinhalb jahren kritisiert
wurde verstehen sie mich bitte nicht
falsch die pandemie war eine wirklich
schwierige zeit weder regierung noch
journalismus sind unfehlbar und ihren
spahn hatte recht als er sagte wir
werden einander verzeihen müssen aber
dafür muss man ja auch erstmal um
entschuldigung mit einer der in der
runde sitzt hat dann nicht mitgemacht er
ist sehr oft die person die freiheit
eingetreten alexander kissler meine
frage ist kam es denn nur mir so vor
oder hatten wir den letzten zweieinhalb
jahren probleme in der deutschen
berichterstattung was die korona
pandemie betrifft ich glaube man muss da
zumindest zwei phasen unterscheiden im
anfangs haben sie auch angedeutet wusste
man ja wirklich nicht wo es lang geht
ein neuer virus von china her kommend
fällt über die welt her stirbt man daran
wer stirbt daran was macht man dagegen
da habe ich vollstes verständnis dass
man da wirklich intim vorsicht war das
war ich auch am anfang ich war auch
sorgen vor ich habe auch nicht so lang
schlecht geschlafen ich hatte einmal
angst als wasser auf meinen kopf regnete
weil ich dachte wenn das kontaminiert
ist dann sterbe ich jetzt also völlig
hysterisch aber dann gab es einen
impfstoff dank hat es doch ziemlich
wirksame maßnahmen und dann hat man
rhetorisch in dem moment das ist
wirklich auf dem weg war in den griff zu
bekommen die ganze partie rhetorisch
aufgerüstet ich habe mal nachgeguckt man
hat auch in der zeit zum beispiel
playoffs geschrieben wir brauchen
ausgrenzung wir müssen einen keil
treiben in die gesellschaft zwischen den
die ein risiko sind und die deren risiko
verursachen wir hatten ganz schlimme
aussagen in der politik zum beispiel der
rheinland pfälzische gesundheitsminister
von der spd hat gesagt wer sich nicht
wird impfen lassen muss damit rechnen
dass man ihn ganz genau beobachtet dass
im totalitären überwachungsstaat sehen
das sind autoritäre redeweisen die einer
gesellschaft nichts zu tun haben dürfen
die sonst für ihre toleranz ihrer
augenhöhe berühmt ist und oft auch zu
recht berühmt ist und ich finde man
müsste zumindest erkennen dass man da
rhetorisch fairere mehrere kilometer
übers ziel hinaus geschossen ist das
betrifft genau so die politik wie auch
die journalisten journalismus muss
generell von ausnahmen abgesehen kritik
seien am regierung und wir haben in
dieser phase der ersten phase zumindest
applaudierende journalisten gestanden
die also praktisch den lorbeerkranz auf
dem haupt von frau merkel damals vor
lauter aber auch später abgesetzt haben
das darf doch nicht sein wir müssen auf
dieser ausgrenzung lernen und für die
künftigen debatten und konflikte
energiekrise stichwort lernen andere
menschen nicht ausgrenzen weil sie
andere meinung haben und der
eigenverantwortung auch etwas mehr
vertrauen als der regierungsdirektor
aber ist denn nicht die kritikfähigkeit
der journalisten jetzt stark gestiegen
also ich habe das gefühl ich habe schon
in der 1 das viele viele medien jetzt
schon deutlich kritischer darauf schauen
und nicht mehr so in diesen applaus
reingehen wie es am anfang dafür war
aber das ist jetzt ja sagen auf der
allerletzten runde wir sind das glaube
ich hier im dritten sogenannten crawler
herbst und die zahlen gehen da wirklich
überall runter wenn man jetzt noch das
gleiche macht aber ich vermisse wirklich
da muss ich ihnen recht geben müssen
will papa ich habe ein bisschen aus
arbeite aber aber ganz ehrlich lange wir
haben ja immer sachen die politik kennen
wir gar nicht aus dem entschuldigen raus
wir haben ja gleich noch die einmal gas
umlage und die konstruktion bleiben
entschuldigen aber wir haben eine
situation gehabt um diese richtig sagen
die eine bedrohung für die
krisensituation war die eine pandemie er
war und es ging um die frage wie retten
wir menschenleben wir dürften es gar
nicht
missverstehen wir hatten ja eine
situation wo das erste virus die erste
variante wirklich mega gefährlich weil
ich hab im bekannten gleichen
journalismus die berichterstattung
ausgewogen ausgewogen weiß wie ich finde
fand schwierig von vielerlei seiten wo
teilweise echt überspitzungen waren wo
man eine spaltung hatte wo es auch
schlagzeilen der bild zeitung gab dienen
so polemisierte haben dass sie mit
getragen
teilweise ging da sachen gegen herrn
lauterbach oder auch der osten wo ich
sagen ist das ist das ist halt drüber
das muss man halt nicht machen in so
einer krisensituation aber das wichtige
ist dass ich bei vielen menschen
wahrgenommen habe das wirklich darum
darum wird mit dieser krise klar zu
kommen und das ist dass eine zentrale
für mich und ich was ich wichtig finde
ist wirklich treffen die kritik
anzubringen also ich bin nicht irgendwie
mich entschuldigen bei irgendwelchen
leuten die mit schwarz weiß roten fahnen
auf die straßen gegangen sind es war
nicht alle demonstranten
deswegen sagt ja ich glaube es ist
wichtig wenn wir aus dieser spaltung
rauskommen wenn wir eine sachliche
diskussion am kommen aber wir brauchen
keine entschuldigung sorgen hätte
herbert ihn ich habe einen schritt von
ihnen mitgebracht heute abend weil sie
haben gerade spaltung angesprochen und
eine spaltung sie sind glaube ich auch
ganz nämlichen empfiehlt positiv an war
zweig ich ja aber es war eine maßnahme
für die sie waren wenn ich den speed
lesen und zwar haben sie nämlich
getwittert sie waren also entweder die
aktuelle notlage ist komplett
überflüssig unnötig wäre mit einer hohen
impfquoten zu vermeiden gewesen wenn
jetzt spd und fdp eine impfpflicht
ausschließen ist das fahrlässig ist eine
meinung die sie heute noch teilen das
war eine impfpflicht brauchen ich glaube
er hat eine situation eine impfpflicht
eine notwendige und richtige maßnahme
gewesen wäre in der hoch-zeit ich glaube
das war der herbst
2020 21 gerne wieder in zwei tagen wer
das massiv im hatten und wo klar war
dass man sozusagen mit dem impfen da
immer raus kommt aus dieser situation da
hatten wir eine vorige variante die
extrem gut angesprochen hat auf diesen
impfstoff das haben wir jetzt bei diesem
omikron variante nicht in dem maße und
zu dem zeitpunkt hätte ich das richtig
an gefunden um aus diesem lockdown aus
dieser bedrängnis situation der nahost
raus gekommen weil menschen können sich
trotzdem gegenseitig anstecken also
geimpften und ungeimpften konnten sich
gegenseitig anstecken egal wie der
impfstoff im status waren da bei dieser
variante hatten wir noch eine andere
situation unter anderem studienlage ja
die impfung namen prozentige
immunisierung versprach
hundertprozentige nicht aber die
wahrscheinlichkeit der übertragung war
zu dem zeitpunkt im wesentlich geringer
haben die studien damals gezeigt zu dem
zeitpunkt bei der variante das war
damals natürlich impfpflicht immer eine
ganz scharfes mittel das wenn sie auch
was natürlich jurist und da muss man
glaube ich etwas vorsichtiger mit
umgehen mit diesem mittel ich bin auch
dafür dass man darüber diskutiert dass
man vor allem den es hat daran hat ja
damals gelegen wir hatten ja nicht genug
impfstoff für die die sich impfen lassen
wollten und hat dann schon darüber
gesprochen die sich nicht immer
verlassen wollten zu zwingen sich zu
impfen also eine völlig absurde
situation aber ein impfpflicht ist zumal
sehr scharfe eingriffe in die
körperliche unversehrtheit mit
selbstbestimmungsrecht über den eigenen
körper der wir sonst sehr hoch halten
und ich habe zu keinem zeitpunkt der
pandemie diese schwelle für für
überschritten geheimnis tagen bin ich
als
medienkonsument mal das revue passieren
lassen was in den letzten zwei jahren
passiert ist muss ich sagen es gibt
einfach eine legitimationskrise des
deutschen journalismus mittlerweile weil
eben nicht ist aber eines großen teils
des journalismus findet keine namen
nennen aber er ist wurde viel von oben
erklärt aber nicht sachlich sondern es
wurde behauptet ihr müsst das und das
machen das ist alternativlos um einen
sprechen aus der politik aufzugreifen
und das hinterlässt natürlich spuren und
wenn ich das jetzt mal auf heute
unterbreche habe ich das große problem
im moment dass ich diese beschwörungen
ja wir müssen wieder uns auf den krisen
winter einstimmen corona wird ganz
schrecklich dieser alarmismus da muss
ich doch als sage mal etwas über die
grenzen schauen der medienkonsument
einfach auch mal gucken was passiert in
den nachbarländern
ich muss ja nicht in den urlaub fahren
um festzustellen dass alle anderen
länder in europa und weltweit die sache
etwas sachlicher und pragmatischer an
gehen also dieser alarmismus dem wir
über monate und jahre jetzt erlebt haben
er hat glaube ich auch der
glaubwürdigkeit der medien sehr
geschadet und man müsste da auch
rhetorisch zurückfahren und wieder zu
einer gewissen sachlichkeit zurückkehren
aber ich finde gerade jetzt wenn man
sich die phase jetzt anguckt dann wird
viel mehr kritisch hinterfragt also
dieser alarmismus sehen sie jetzt
angesprochen haben deswegen man hat
natürlich gesehen es gab prognosen wo
viele politiker falsch gelegen haben da
haben wir auch als journalisten daraus
gelernt es war ja eine extreme phase die
wir alle nicht kannten und wenn jetzt
irgendwelche horror prognosen für den
herbst und für den winter kommen dann
finde ich das das aus den medien viel
stärker hinterfragt wenn ich bin ein
guter leiter und jetzt meine ich ein
gutes beispiel ist lauterbach als
gesundheitsminister als er
gesundheitsminister geworden ist gab es
ja auch sozialen medien hypes nach dem
motto endlich wird lauterbach der
einzige der sich wissenschaftlich damit
auskennt gesundheitsminister und scholz
wurde quasi dazu gedrängt dass halperin
der musste ja das was man isst er werde
und dann haben aber sehr viele medien
auch lauterbach kritisch hinterfragt und
meiner meinung nach auch sehr stark
entzaubert und deswegen hat sich das
schon eine ganze menge die jahr wurde
der ton in weiten bereichen den medien
ist nach wie vor schritt ja und es
herrscht ein alarmismus den ich im
moment jetzt wieder wahrnehmen jetzt
kommt der herbst jetzt müssen wir alle
angst haben jetzt müssen gibt es große
probleme aber diese weiter diese
argumentation zieht eben letztendlich
für den sachlich orientierten
medienkonsument nicht mehr sondern der
braucht eben sozusagen abwägungen da
muss ich auch ganz einfach sagen ich
habe die tage auf twitter geschrieben
ich bin jetzt hier fach geimpft und ich
bin kein impfgegner aber ich respektiere
jeden der es anders sieht und das ist
doch die einstellung mit der auch die
medien da rangehen müssen dass man sagt
wir informieren euch und ihr könnt die
entscheidung hätte sie sind übrigens ich
glaube jetzt gerade werden viele
jugendliche ihre fans weil es gibt eine
neue studie die besagt dass vor allem
bei den jugendlichen medien ein ganz
großes glaubwürdigkeitsproblem haben
also vor allem die jugendlichen
vertrauen unserer berichterstattung
eigentlich mails business insider
spricht ja auch vor allem die jungen
leute an aber ich habe diese studie
heute auch gelegentlich schon echt
schockiert da geht es um über 70 prozent
der befragten die kein vertrauen in die
medien haben und da müssen wir uns
natürlich auch ohne frage kritisch
hinterfragen weil das ist natürlich
etwas ganz heftiges wenn wir die jungen
leute nicht erreichen wenn er später
noch auf die öffentlich-rechtlich
gekommen die erreichen die leute sowieso
nicht aber wir müssen natürlich schauen
dass wir diese jungen leute erreichen
weil da bilden sich meinungen und das
geht nicht nur durch ins trotzdem machen
jetzt direkt man mit dem zweiten großen
thema weiter was die presse ja aktuell
beschäftigt ohne es ja etwas eher
hintergrund geraten und das ist die lage
der wirtschaft und vor allem die energie
lage und da hat uns herr putin heute ein
thema mitgebracht